okay you might know about this case
against Donald Trump's Trump University
a total scam i mean just absolute bottom
of the barrel scam okay there's a case
they're naturally numerous cases against
Trump University and Donald Trump's
attorneys are now saying wait a second
Trump is now president-elect he's going
to be very busy figuring out how his
administration is going to run we should
postpone the hearing the trial against
Trump University until after Trump is
sworn in filing a motion on saturday
night saying let's move it from November
28 to sometime after the january
twentieth inauguration of President
Donald Trump and they say we just can't
get in the way of Trump getting ready to
be President of the United States now
this is such nonsense on a number of
levels number one the idea that once he
is President Donald Trump will have way
more time to deal with a fraud case
against this scam university makes no
sense whatsoever but number two we also
are aware of the fact that when you have
a sitting president on the other end of
a trial that is going to be something
that will make it very difficult to get
an impartial jury how do you get an
impartial jury Pat to hear a case
against the President of the United
States you possibly can't because I'm
sure most the people on that jury not
most of them but some of them voted for
Trump probably yeah and of course you
can't use who they voted for as a basis
to either include or disqualify them
from inclusion on the jury there are
three of these civil cases against Trump
University the first one goes on trial
in front of a judge or the the trial
starts preceding start on November 28th
uh trial delay really effective tool but
for people who have lawsuits against
them you just delay delay delay this
will make it more likely that the
plaintiffs will settle because very
often they really need money and Trump
has won many lawsuits in this way if you
combine that with being president of the
United States it's pretty bad now that
being said I don't really see what the
big deal is Mike Pence is mostly going
to be doing all the presidential stuff
once they're sworn in any way and Trump
said he's not even looking live at the
White House full time so maybe Trump
will
have a lot of free time to deal with
this once he's sworn in I just really
can't get over the fact that he thinks
he's going to be less busy once he takes
office this is just an excuse to push
this off I think it is a delay tactic
yet no doubt about his lawyers know that
this is just something you do and then
hey you know what now he's president
let's delay for years and maybe we'll
just never get to these cases against
Trump University that's what we are
preparing for ladies and gentlemen over
the next four years after the break I
will speak to Ray Comfort known to many
as banana man happen to have a banana
here with me today back after this